if I Machado Gary can weather this storm
and get a highlight reel knockout over
Vicente luk as he goes on to be world
champion this will be the fight that was
the Make It or Break It moment in this
young Fighter's career and there is so
much pressure on him there's so much
noise I think if he can just somehow get
over the hump and do what he does best
which is fighting inside that octagon
and if he can get a knockout which I
think he does over viente luk it's going
to propel him to levels that he couldn't
even imagine and that that's why I do
what I do that's why I do this show
that's why I continue to support the UFC
for these exact moments it's it's the
guys come ups that I love it's what
keeps me involved in the sport it's what
I get most excited for to me it's the
come up the the Conor McGregor come up
if you remember those days those were so
special there's nothing like it in
sports it's what makes the UFC the best
and Ian Machado Gary is he's that guy
and he has the chance to pull that off
Saturday night